- [Cat] In the playoff
we're fuckin' killing them.
- That's right, you've won
a playoff series finally
- Finally, finally.
(Gary laughs)
- K. Leonard's doing his thing.
- [Nat] No and he's gonna leave us.
- You know what's funny,
that's obviously the thought.
Sometimes this kind of level of,
what people always underestimate
is people falling in love with a city.
- [Nat] True.
- The strategy is hey,
I'm gonna go play for the Clippers,
but then all of a sudden
you've lived there for a year.
You know, I don't know
his, like if he's married.
- [Nat] Yeah, he's married with kids.
He lives in a nice neighborhood.
- So there you go.
Right, all of a sudden wife
makes the best friend of her life.
She starts chirping.
Like you just never know,
like there's so many, I mean it happened
with Paul George in Oklahoma City.
That was supposed to be a pit
stop and he was gonna go to LA
and what happened was
he fell in love with it.
I know I'm getting a little
bit sports nardy, sorry.
- [Cat] Oh, well we have--
- [Nat] We only know our teams.
(she laughs)
- How well?
What about the Leafs?
Devastating.
You hate Boston, too.
- [Nat] Well, my husband's from Boston so,
I don't know, I'm not like--
- You definitely hate Boston.
I'm just kidding.
(they laugh)
- [Man] They know what a caller is.
- [Nat] Yeah.
- Oh is that right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's awesome.
- [Nat] Kevin and Mat.
Mat helped us make the game.
- Makes a ton of sense.
- [Nat] Coming together?
- Coming together.
Well at least the game part.
Actually, I'd think do
the caller in thing,
but like the game part now.
- [Nat] Yeah, he came to us.
He's like I gotta--
- He's the best.
- [Nat] He's such a nice guy.
Like you guys need to have a game.
- He's the best guy.
- [Nat] Yeah.
- He's the best caller in boy.
- [Nat] Yeah, he beats Kevin?
- I love him.
I just want to be razzing Kevin.
(she laughs)
'Cause Kevin's actually
my real, real friend.
We're good?
312?
- [Crew] Yes, sir.
- Hey everybody it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and it's episode 312.
I've been flubbing that.
I flubbed it yesterday.
This is episode 312 of
the "AskGaryVee Show"
and it's an exciting one
because we're drinking wine
and playing games and
based on what's happened
in the first two minutes here off screen,
the energy is real.
The one plus one equals eleven here
is very real with these two lovely ladies.
And ladies why don't you tell
the Vayner Nation who you are
and what you're about.
- I like this.
- Yo, I'm Nat.
- I'm cat.
- That's Cat and Nat.
- Yeah, Cat and Nat.
We have seven children
between the two of us.
I mean what we--
- [Gary] Does one have
six and the other have one
is that what--
- Can you imagine?
- Yeah, I got six.
- [Gary] No, no, no.
- Three and four.
- Yes, but they're one.
You know what I mean?
They roll together.
- They do it all together.
- And we--
- [Gary] Will there be an eighth?
- There should be but we need a donor.
Because--
- My husband's done, but I'm ready to go.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- [Cat And Nat] Yeah.
- We think about having a baby together.
- We don't know how to
make it happen though.
- [Gary] Nate?
- Ya, Nate are you available?
- [Nat] Oh, that is so cute.
- [Cat] That's so cute.
(Nat laughs)
We should film that, that would be fun.
We can vlog it.
We could have a new show.
I love it.
- [Gary] A huge promotion for Empathy.
(both laugh)
Babies always sell wine.
- Yeah and oh puppies.
We could get a dog and a baby--
- And the more babies the more wine.
- Yeah, seven children and,
I mean we give the speil
of the human side and then
we have a business side.
What side do you want?
Business or human?
- [Gary] Me business.
- [Cat] You business,
okay the business side.
- What does that mean though,
we give the business side
and human side so what
you guys actually do.
Like everybody here is like
just getting to know you.
You're already on third base.
I want you to come back to first base.
- [Nat] So we created a
business through the a need
that we were looking for.
We wanted a place where
moms could come together
in a nonjudgmental place
where it'd be positive
and fun and there was nothing
in our city at the time.
- Physically.
- [Nat] Physically.
- [Cat] We did it physically.
- We created an event club
- Just wanted to follow.
- [Cat] in Toronto.
We brought together women, unfortunately--
- That's interesting.
- [Nat] Yeah, very interesting.
- I'd like that, when did you do that?
- [Cat] With wine and without babies.
So with wine.
It was always with wine
and without children
so you could have a conversation.
- Right, you're like these old dudes
have like the Elks club.
- [Cat And Nat] Yeah.
- We need a young woman
club where we can hang.
Shit on our husbands, let loose and live.
- And finally finish a conversation,
because when babies are there
your brain is like, rattled.
- [Gary] Right, 'cause you're
actually on paying attention,
so they don't choke?
- Yeah.
- And we needed to sell
tickets because moms,
are flaky, don't get mad but they are,
so they're like they have
the best intentions to go out
and then come 5 o'clock
they're like fuck it.
The babysitter--
- I see, so in real life,
'cause I've seen this.
Right like if you're just getting together
with your friends inevitably oh, yeah,
all eight of us are gonna get together,
we'll drink some wine, catch up
and then it's two and a half.
- [Cat] Yes, always.
So we're like--
- The half is somebody
comes after rush hour.
- Absolutely.
- So we're like charge
them, make them show up,
get them out of the house.
We thought we were winning
because we made like $100
and we were like--
- [Gary] You were pumped.
- Oh, yeah.
- We were pumped.
We are two stay-at-home moms.
- And we were making moms happy
and they felt like they
had a place to belong.
We were like oh we're doing this--
- First night's over.
You look at each other.
You're like we had fun
and we made 100 bucks,
we're geniuses.
- [Nat] Yeah, totally.
- [Cat] Guess who didn't say that?
- Who?
- [Cat] The husbands.
- Why, what did they say only 100 bucks?
- You didn't just go there for an hour
and have a good time.
You took all that time to plan the event,
get the sponsors, get the speakers.
- You know who's always wrong?
- [Nat] The husbands.
- The husbands.
- I like that, please say
that because so many women.
No, no so many women--
- [Gary] This is my single
most viral clip every.
- Say this.
- [Gary] Like when I
post this on Instagram,
and say husbands are 100% wrong.
This is gonna go viral as fuck.
- [Nat] Women are gonna love ya.
- Women say to us, I have a passion,
I have a hobby, but it doesn't pay.
And I'm like does it give you
something outside of the house
and that if you--
- There is nothing more devastating to me
in the world of
entrepreneurship then wives
who have ideas who then
first go to their husband
and their husbands shoot
it down out of one truth,
the husband's insecure.
Deep in the soul of a
husband is an insecurity
that if, God forbid, my
wife goes and does this
and she makes more money then me
and in that, in our world,
there are so many ideas
by women today that will
never see the day of life
because the woman is also insecure
and when she gets the negative
feedback, she shelves it.
It's double insecurity and we
need to make a call of action
right now that women need
to see through their ideas.
When they're in a marriage.
- Yes, the only thing that
really helped for us, too,
I think and we, is that we had each other.
And we gave each other the
confidence to keep going,
even if everyone around us was telling us
we were crazy.
- But it was not like
we'd say we had a quote
in our last podcast
that was like we had, if
there was a brick wall,
a tornado, a hurricane, a
fire, another brick wall,
we had to go around that, over that,
because we had seven children
at home and no child care.
So we could not actually
leave until someone came home,
which was our husbands on their clock
and then we could leave.
So we had to find a way to
make an income to even leave
to pay a babysitter in
order to pursue something
- [Gary] I totally understand.
- that we felt passionate about.
- And oh, by the way, oh by
the way, this is important.
This is why your story is so important.
I'm super pumped hearing this.
And so is a version for everybody.
Yeah, you know like when
people like, this level of like
people are entitled to
success is a problem.
Like somebody hit me up the other day,
Gary, you talk about working for free
or like working for nothing.
Like how do I do that
living in the Bay area?
I'm like move dick.
- [Nat And Cat] Yes.
- Gary, I can't do what you're saying,
I live in Buschwick.
I'm like move to deep,
deep, deep Long Island.
- Yeah, yeah, and that's another thing
is that we never wanted, we
never wanted to take money from,
and people were like
get investors, you can--
- Go to the bank.
- I love you guys.
- We're not gonna spend any money
to make money.
- We're gonna make money.
- [Gary] Love you.
- I learnt the fucking Google algorithms,
the worm, the crawl, the shit.
I sat there with my baby in bed
and like what the fuck is this?
We learned everything on our own.
- [Gary] Love you,
love you so much.
- We hired nobody.
- [Gary] Love you.
- And I think, I'll tell us this year
we'll be a multimillion company as of
we're into our second
million, like as a product.
We have more than, so we split,
when I tell you did not take
a dime until we made a dime.
We did not use a dime until
we had more than two dimes.
- Did either one of you
have an entrepreneurial spirit as a kid?
Sell bracelets, candy, you have any?
- So we got kicked out of high school.
- [Gary] Together?
- Separately.
- But we did go to high school together.
- [Gary] You guys have
known each other since when?
- Ninth grade.
- Ready, fun fact.
Greg and I we met.
We--
- [Gary] How does it go down?
- We would used to skip school,
get high.
- Go to her mom's house
get high and eat bagels.
- Okay, so now the three of
you meet or see each other
and you're like oh,
we're both loser chicks.
Let's be friends.
- We don't fit in anywhere.
We don't fit, I've a learning disability.
I've never done well at school.
I've always been the rogue one.
So I'm sitting there and I'm
like the teacher goes to me,
the teacher's like--
- This is my report card.
We gotta a new frame.
No, no look.
- [Nat] I need to see it.
- Look.
- 30%, no 30.
- No, no, look at the grades.
- [Cat] Well, you were really good.
- At gym.
(Nat laughs)
- No I see Ds, Ds, Cs, As.
- [Gary] No, there's one A.
- In gym?
- I got four As in high
school, all in gym.
Everything else is Ds and Fs.
- I didn't even get
- That was us.
- one of these.
I was like fail, fail.
I was like I'm working my ass off.
- [Gary] In Canada?
- [Both] Yeah.
- [Gary] They did just
pass and fail that's why.
- No, no.
- No, we did grades.
- [Gary] Oh you did.
- We just did you know going to school--
- [Gary] Did you graduate high school?
- No, no.
- I did.
- [Gary] I love you.
You are my favorite.
You didn't graduate high school.
- No.
- I'm fuckin' fired up.
I'm so jealous of you.
I so deeply wish I didn't
graduate high school.
- [Nat] Yeah I did.
- [Cat] She didn't do it
at a traditional school.
- [Nat] I did it in night
school and summer school
'cause it was the only way I could focus.
- [Cat] Yeah, we don't have it.
- Where did they send you?
- [Cat] I just, I went to work.
- I fucking love you.
- [Cat] I just--
- What did your parents think?
- My mom was in New York and got,
I have kind of a fucked up story,
but it's on the podcast.
But, I--
- It's in the book too.
- Two things, it's in the book two.
So we come from single moms.
When I was a young girl my mom
lived in a cabin in the woods.
No electricity, no
toilet, no running water,
we lived--
- [Gary] You're a woods baby?
- I meant, I'm a woods
baby, for few years.
We used to wake up in the
morning, stuff papers,
throw papers and then go to school before
so we could make extra income.
- [Gary] Love it.
- We'd like roll quarters
so we could like get to go
the community center for
50 cents, I remember that
to go swimming.
So then, she also is from a single mom
who's now thrown into the single mom world
and has to go to work.
So we have two moms, we're living--
- Got it, so your
situation's more divorce,
oh, fuck I gotta go into the work world.
- [Both] Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] Got it.
- So we're sitting there and
we've watched these women.
My mom used to always
apologize 'cause she would work
all the time, around the clock, right.
She eventually became the
vice president of a bank.
Started as, like she also
didn't finish university,
and worked her way up.
So I watched her.
Now, that being said,
what drove us was the fact
that we never fit in but
together we felt like
we had an energy that people
would watch us, not talk to us.
They would be like, they
would want to know more
from us about our
experiences, what we did.
- And that's how it grew
from the event space,
was then we started to,
people everywhere was like
I want you to come to my city.
Well, we can't go everywhere,
so how can we get to you?
How can we get into your living room
and still be with Cat and Nat?
We can livestream.
There was no livestream on YouTube.
We found software to make it happen.
A year later--
- Someone else was like
get a business plan.
And we're like fuck that.
We're just gonna go.
Someone wanted us to sit down
like you need five years.
I don't even know what's
gonna happen tomorrow,
but I know what we can
do is go from our gut
And every day when something felt right,
we were like that feels right
and then it was more of what we needed
and when it felt right to us--
- You guys stayed insular.
My number one thesis on this
is life is to stay insular.
That's what you did.
- But I think we have the
raw feelings from our parents
to know what feels right.
- That is the same reason
why we would never take money
from anyone else because--
- Guys, adversity is the
foundation of success.
- And you know how you get confidence?
By fucking up.
- Yeah, that's how
you become resilient.
- And you know how you
get self-esteem, by fucking failing.
Like all that shit you have--
- Once you get used to
everyone shitting on you,
you can't taste their shit.
(both laugh)
- We're so used to failing
it's like not a surprise.
It's a surprise when we succeed.
Someone says yes, we're like
really?
- Holy fuck.
- Shh, can't wait to--
- [Gary] You're actually kind of--
- No, we're more comfortable--
- Kind of.
- [Cat] No, no, we're more--
- It's fun to say, but when people--
- [Nat] No, honestly we
are honestly surprised
when we succeed, we really are.
- That's where we're different.
- We're very comfortable
in a place where no one--
- Okay so you guys do this event.
Like the first one goes well.
You're like, you get intoxicated
by the action.
- Oh, we keep going.
- You keep going.
It starts building.
- [Nat] People online.
- Come to Chicago.
We can't we got seven fucking kids.
You go live streaming.
Then what happens?
- Yeah, then we go to fucking Germany.
We call someone in Germany.
We don't actually go.
- 'Cause he's got the software.
- [Gary] 'Cause he's got the push.
Who knew this was going to Germany?
- Yeah, and we find a software in Germany
that they can livestream on a website.
- He's just a dude, like just a dude.
- Livestream wasn't a thing yet.
So we're calling the German.
- [Gary] What was the dude's name?
- Ah, make him look it up.
- Sven, Sven.
So Sven and I are like talking.
- [Gary] Negotiating.
- We're talking to like Sven, okay
and we're like so this isn't working.
It was glitchy.
But we were like fuck it,
20 people were watching.
We were like we're gonna keep going.
- We're having a good time.
- 20's better than zero.
- Yeah, 20 and then even 300.
We were like 300 people watching this.
We're doing the right thing.
- [Gary] And what are you guys doing?
Like just drinking and yelling?
(both laugh)
- [Cat] Are we yelling now?
- [Gary] No, but you know.
- Okay, 'cause we try,
I mean we aren't loud.
- Okay this is
a fun fact.
- Are we yelling?
I'm yelling?
- So we people tried to put
us in space of properness
and crafting and meals
and everyone was YouTube
experts at the time.
- Like just moms.
They wanted us to do mom shit.
- They wanted us to be mom experts.
So we tried it and the camera would go off
and we'd be like this is,
we would be that bad.
- We weren't good at it.
- Fucking shitty.
We were terrible.
- You weren't good at not being yourself.
- Yeah, that's right.
'Cause we had to learn that.
And then what we did
was we went to Instagram
and we started to begin to
just sort of talk about--
- And what was the account?
Individually or you made a joint one?
- Always together.
Everything, email, everything's together.
We're--
- Like who's email is
that, it doesn't matter.
- Do you guys ever fight?
- [Both] No.
- Really?
That's awesome.
By the way, I asked you
that with the belief
that you were gonna
actually answer that way.
I actually believe there are many,
there are relationships
to be had in the world
that actually have that truth.
- Yeah, but you wanna know why?
- Why?
- This is fucked up are you ready?
- I'm always ready for fucked up.
Do you know where you are right now?
(Nat laughs)
We're living fucked up.
I love fucked up.
- We're twin flames.
Which means we're one soul
divided into two bodies.
- We've been together for all our lives.
- Is this some weird shit?
You guys have a weird
lady that told you this?
- [Nat] Yes, she did.
- You fucking guys.
- And then, and then, it was really--
- She told you, guys I'm
about to start that business.
I would have said
- Do it.
- that to you right now.
By flipping over a card
with a rhinoceros on it
and one with like a two of spades.
I'm like you're a twin
fucking flame split in one.
- No, this is what happened in the end.
- [Gary] Thank you very much, 500 bucks.
- Stop it.
- [Gary] Gary's a fucking genius.
- We didn't pay her.
- We were supposed to pay $500
and in the end we ended up
teaching her.
- Charging her.
- [Cat] Counseling her.
She's like I've never
told anybody this before.
But I just feel so comfortable
with you guys.
- she's sharing everything.
She's like this is my life.
- Let me tell you something this is where
the three of us share this.
I understand why that happened.
Humans don't understand
this one unbelievable truth,
when you have the courage
to be 100% yourself
the world will lean into you at scale.
That's what's happened to you.
- And we feel that all the time
with everyone who calls us.
Every time we go on tour
and meet these women.
They tell us their secrets.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Our email is like a confessional.
People are like,
- [Gary] Of course.
- I have never said this
but I feel I can tell you.
- My DMs are so crazy.
Like it's crazy.
- Yeah, the secrets we could
tell, but it's safe with us
and that's for sure.
- So we always had to figure
out how to make money, right?
So we--
- [Gary] By the way, you need
to make that an Instagram,
like quote.
- Yeah.
- What?
- Secrets are safe with us,
that's for sure.
- They are.
But they always are because
fuck it, we gain nothing
from sharing them.
- I got lots os secrets.
- You've never fought?
- [Both] No.
- Did you ever like the same boy?
- No, we don't.
- Never.
- [Gary] In high school,
you guys didn't like the same boy, ever?
- [Both] No.
- [Gary] Interesting.
You like different types of dudes?
- [Nat] Yeah.
- We're very different.
Wow was that bad?
Fuck yeah.
- She's like I'm completely
not attracted to your husband.
(all laugh)
- [Gary] Listen that's
the way the world works.
- Fair, right.
- What's the best thing
that ever happened?
- Well, I mean we would
we fuck the same person.
Maybe.
- Yeah, sure.
- But would we fall in love
with the same person, no.
- No.
- [Gary] It depends on
how much Empathy Wine
you drink, right?
(both laugh)
I get it, I get it.
- No, we, okay this is the truth.
I think because of where we,
I was a social worker before I did this.
- And I was a stripper.
- I actually ended up going,
a stripper that's how we met.
I was.
- She was there to like bring
me back, you'll be okay, girl.
- You see where I would
be the better stripper.
- I know that.
- Okay--
- So why didn't you do it?
- [Nat] Right?
- Life is long Gary, life is long.
- [Gary] I know life is long.
(all laugh)
- Life is long.
- You should see the
things she does on stage.
It's a little bit stripperish.
- That's a talent.
- Give the fans what they want.
- It's a talent.
So anyways.
- Our friendship, the
reason we don't fight, too.
Is it's so important.
Like what we're doing is
so important the things
that people tell us about our friendship
that resonates with people.
- Yeah, but that's now.
You know what's, to your point,
like that's what's so special
about the relationship.
That makes sense now.
You have this big thing that is,
but you guys were 14, you were 16.
- [Cat] No, I'm gonna tell you something.
- You were 18, you were 22.
- No, stop right there
because we were just not like,
motherhood was what brought us together
'cause we had babies.
- [Gary] Interesting, that makes sense.
- And it was fucked up when
you have your first kid.
- [Gary] So you guys like
were friends in high school.
- And then--
- [Gary] Did your.
- Separate things.
- I saw her in this club once.
- I was up on the table.
- She was like oh.
- I like to table dance.
Anyways, what we did--
- We were the first of
anyone to have babies
and we were in the deep, dark
hole, helping each other.
- Like what like the fuck is this?
- [Nat] What the fuck is
this, found each other.
- [Cat] I was a social worker.
This is no problem.
It was a fucking problem.
You know, all those things.
So that was very confusing for us
and that's how we reconnected
and never left each other.
But I will tell you if you are
in a business with a partner
for us, I don't know if
this is a woman thing
or partner thing, but nothing is 50/50
it's whoever needs more that day.
So sometimes,
- [Gary] That's a partnership.
- She picks up--
- That's how it works.
- Right, so.
- Good for you.
But by the way, the fact
that you both understand that
is game, that was the
biggest insight for me
as I'm getting to know you.
That makes, good for you.
Do you know how hard that is for people?
- [Nat] I know.
- Yeah, but it's the
betterment of the person
I spend my time with and vice-versa.
- [Gary] I totally understand.
- I'll pick you up, you'll pick me up.
- But you know what?
Inevitable DNA it's cute in theory.
Like, hey today,
sometimes that shit can last for a year.
- [Cat] It has.
- I'm sure it has.
Sometimes that thing could be, by the way,
sometimes it just
actually gonna be forever.
Listen I've been in business partnerships
with my dad and my brother.
And from a pure merit of who
can drive the most revenue
for the business, this is
no disrespect to my dad
or my brother, I would
only say it out loud
because I know they would
say it out loud as well.
They will never be my equal.
Even though one, my dad
owned 100% of Wine Library
and AJ was 50/50 with me at
Vayner and never were they,
and that takes my ability
to be okay with that.
That takes a level of humility,
empathy and true love.
Father, brother, easy.
Friends, that's incredible
that you guys can do that.
- Cat likes to say swallow
your pride, swallow your balls.
- Swallow your balls.
- Just swallow your balls
you'll be okay with it.
- A lot of men
have a hard time being like,
we work with a lot of men.
- By the way, let me save
you time on this for real.
I know, I get it.
But like, and women, humans.
- [Nat] Yes, true, got it.
- Listen, please, humans right.
Listen one of the things
I'm very passionate about
is men and women are clearly different.
That's just, let's get to that point.
And people have like a
tough time with that.
- [Nat] I always, I have such a tough time
I can't believe men are
supposed to marry women
and we're supposed to marry
men because we're so different.
We don't see eye to eye on anything.
- So what do you think should happen?
- Well I just think it's crazy.
- Yeah, we're--
- I'm not against this theory.
I'd much rather hang out
all the time with Nate.
Yeah, he's a friend.
- You come and visit.
- [Gary] Would you marry me?
- Yes.
- [Cat] Wait are we
having a baby with Nate?
- I just came back from
Qatar 24 hours ago.
Four wives, three wives.
I'm like wow.
It's just culture.
Like it seems insane to us.
It's normal as fuck.
- What's, what's insane?
Everything's normal.
You know what, everything's
normal for that--
- Everything's normal.
- [Cat] Everything's normal
- Yeah, but everyone's,
you're supposed to have one,
they're supposed to marry,
they're supposed to do these things.
For us we're like, I don't
really understand it--
- Do your husbands get along?
- Yes.
- Oh, they do?
- And they're both named Mark.
- Fucked up.
- But they had no choice.
And you know what?
- They do have a choice.
I think you guys would have allowed it.
You guys are awesome.
- [Nat] Yeah, it actually would.
- Your strength is very
obvious to me already.
You would have allowed it.
- [Nat] Probably would have let them.
- [Gary] Exactly.
- We would have made it work.
- Listen, everything's figure-outable.
- No, but really, they get along?
- [Cat] Yes, they get along.
- What are their common interests?
Golf, the Maple Leafs?
- You know what,
no I think they're just
respectful people to each other.
- That's awesome but do
they have a common interest?
- [Nat] Us and the kids.
- [Gary] Makes sense, the kids.
- And so when we travel a lot--
- [Gary] But they're
different interest dudes?
- [Both] Yes.
- Okay, what are they?
Like what's your husband into as a dude?
Like what are his hobbies or interests?
- He likes sports, he's big into sports.
- [Gary] Playing or watching?
- He was a hockey player.
- He was in the NHL.
- He was in the NHL?
What?
Now, I know why.
- Well, now you know what?
- [Gary] I didn't know nothing.
I just said it.
- He gets zero credit
for anything I've said.
This is only--
- [Gary] Who'd he play for?
- A lot.
He got--
- [Gary] How many years
did he play in the NHL?
- Well, he played up and down in the NHL--
- [Gary] Between minor leagues in the NHL?
- Yeah, then the strike
came and like all the shit.
He was--
- He was a fighter.
He was an enforcer.
My kids YouTube his fights,
like gentle giant.
- But someone once said to me,
he's the nicest guy off the ice.
You never wanna meet him on the ice.
- Right, punch people
in the fucking mouth.
- [Cat] Fuck them up.
- That's how I am in business.
Actually I'm a nice person, I
just wanna destroy your face.
- And he did destroy their faces.
- Clearly.
- Destroy physically.
(Cat laughs)
- Yeah, that's hockey.
My favorite thing about hockey players
is how fucked up their faces are.
- [Nat] Yeah, he's fucked up.
- Ears, teeth.
- [Cat] Fake teeth, fake
arms, legs, fake shoulder.
- [Nat] His whole face is fucked up,
but he's still really handsome.
- Yeah, very.
- Okay, let's put
that out there.
- You know there is something interesting
about hockey players.
I think the nature of
hockey makes hockey players
more handsome than they are for some--
- Oh, you are so right, yes.
- Thank you, I've been
trying to figure this out
for a long time.
- They're like more handsome on a whole.
- I believe that when you
say you're a hockey player.
That there's something
that makes you a handsome,
hot guy that if that same guy
was like I'm a computer
programmer, he's not as hot.
- It filter's a status.
Because you got to
where most people can't.
- It's so fucked up.
The nature of hockey,
unlike baseball, basketball,
is they all have, you get the
puck hits your fucking face.
They fight.
It's a rugged, fucking sport.
- [Nat] That is hot.
- That's hot.
All right, thank you.
(Nat growls)
- Or there's a rare kind of
like, look as we all progress
there is still animalistic
cores to our world.
We are still animals.
- [Cat] Agreed.
- So, a hockey player that man is creating
a little bit of that rawness.
Like listen, you could say
anything you want about society,
there's still an underlying tone of like,
- [Cat] Fight or flight
is still there.
- if your man punches
another man in the face,
there's something you like about it.
That's how I judge my friends.
(Nat laughs)
- [Cat] Who punches who?
- I absolutely judge people.
Nate, who's my, guys let's go very meta.
We're drinking Empathy Wines right now.
This is our business, right.
We've been doing some stuff.
What's that?
- [Nat] We're about to get married
and we're about to have a baby.
Are you two Like really good friends?
- No, we're actually probably,
I've been so busy lately our friendship
and Nate did a bad job
with the Jets last year
and he's got a very serious girlfriend.
We've been busy on the bridges.
- [Nat] Ah.
- I'd actually argue that our friendship
is at weak point right now,
but in the macro forever.
Right, Nate, wouldn't you agree?
We're just busy.
- [Nat] You guys should work on that.
- He was my, when Zander
was born and he was my admin
and like we were playing
tennis all the time.
Like, I'm very mad at Nate,
because he's gotten very into,
he's got very into his girlfriend.
- [Nat] His girlfriend?
(Nat laughs)
- And very serious back into golf.
Which doesn't allow me
to penetrate my wants
and needs of what he should be into
which right now is sports cars.
- [Cat] You don't like golf, right?
- No, I hate it.
- [Cat] Fucking yes.
- But I'm naturally great at it.
I think or at least Nate tells
me I could be good at it.
I believe him.
'Cause I have disproportionately
good eye-hand coordination.
I established that on
Instagram the other night.
- [Nat] As in gym, As in gym.
- As in gym.
I'm a gym class hero.
But I want Nate to be into sports cars
and the Jets.
- [Nat] And he's not?
- Right now he's into
golf and his girlfriend.
And by the way, this is the good part,
and the business of Empathy Wines.
- Nate sounds a bit boring right now.
- No, no, he's loving it.
He loves golfing.
By the way, Nate should
be a professional golfer.
- [Cat] All right, Nate,
let's work on that.
- Actually we like Nate.
Nate's a good time.
- Nate's a great time.
- Yeah.
- A great time?
- Yeah, we chatted.
- We laughed.
- We forced him to open wine for us,
but he did.
- We had fun with him.
- Yeah, like about.
- [Both] Are you jealous?
- Guys, no I'm not jealous.
You guys hung out with
him for three minutes.
- [Cat] No, we've been here since 11:30.
- [Nat] Oh, yeah, We've been hanging out.
Oh yeah, Gary.
- Dawson's shaking his head.
- [Cat] We've been here for awhile.
- We haven't--
- Where was I going?
I love Nate, going backwards, happy life.
Oh, Nate is only sitting in this room,
because when he was an
intern we went up to Vermont
and played volleyball and his ruggedness
and shear will to win and
like competitive spirit,
and he's an intern, and I'm
on the other side of the net.
CO, the guy, dada, and
he doesn't give a fuck.
And I'm like, I like this kid.
- Hey, we were asking before
is there in 10 years has he
ever come close to being fired?
He doesn't think so.
- Not Nate, no.
Phil did.
- Phil.
- And Tyler.
Both, Phil and Tyler.
- Phil and Tyler.
- Tyler, get Tyler right now.
- [Nat] We want Tyler.
- Tyler.
- He almost got fired?
- What did he do?
- [Gary And Nat] Tyler.
- Come in here.
- Tyler, Tyler.
You almost caught fire to our kid?
Shit.
They're gonna break his balls right now.
- Tyler, get in here.
Hope on the mic real quick.
Tell the story about the
time you almost got fired.
Speak--
- [Tyler] We talked about it yesterday?
- What?
- About the Jets?
- Oh, the Jets.
- What's that?
- You almost got fired by the Jets?
- [Tyler] I almost got fired,
well I almost got fired.
- Actually, Tyler's
almost been fired twice.
The first time.
- [Tyler] Oh, when we came out--
- The real shit.
I'm not kidding, not
the bullshit Jets one.
Real quick, Tyler becomes
AJ, my brother's admin.
The first thing, he's my admin,
before that he did community management
for Twitter responding for the Jets.
The first day he's in
my inbox, as an admin,
for A.J. 'cause he switched
from community management.
The Jets send an email,
AJ we'd like to talk to
you about Tyler Schmidt,
we'd like him removed
from the Jet's account.
- [Tyler] Which was like
the most important thing
in the frickin' world.
That was the first email I
ever opened as AJ's assistant.
I talked to him maybe five times.
I walk in his office, I'm like--
- What did you do, Tyler?
- [Tyler] I walked in
his office and said so,
that email and he's like get out of here.
- [Nat] No, what did you do wrong?
- [Tyler] Oh.
- He sucked at community management.
- [Tyler] That's,
prioritized in correctly.
- You've learned.
- Yeah.
- But tell about
when you actually almost got fired.
- [Tyler] I really almost got fired
when I was working for him.
- [Gary] Tell the story, I
love how you're gonna tell it.
- Come on, Tyler.
- [Tyler] How am I gonna tell the story?
- I'm gonna drink this
Empathy White first time.
It's delicious.
Pre-order now, empathywines.com.
- [Tyler] I was on the
verge of falling in love
with a very beautiful woman.
- [Nat] This is romantic.
- Nate, this an incredible story.
- Are you still with her?
- [Tyler] No.
- Come on, go.
- [Tyler] No, no, no, no, no.
- We're here for it.
- I'll add color commentary.
Tyler was batting so over his head.
And didn't understand how to calibrate it.
Keep going, Tyler.
- [Tyler] And I got caught,
because I was not doing
much at all workwise.
- [Gary] 'Cause he was so
incapable of calibrating
how he was batting so over his head.
That he was like, what's
happening in my life.
- [Nat] She was really beautiful.
- Yes, go ahead.
- Yeah.
- It's over to you, Tyler.
- Total package.
I appreciate that.
And we were taking a piss.
- Together, the girl and you?
- No, me and Gary.
- Which is so weird about guys.
They pee together.
- In the bathroom
and I'm like I looked at
him and he looked at me
and we were like I think
there's an issue going on.
- No, not me.
I looked him in the face and he said,
you have a problem.
- Yes, and I was like I do have a problem.
More or less.
- Over a pee.
- [Gary] We went back to the office.
- And, yeah, I mean--
- [Gary] What did I say?
- You looked up and then we
talked on the phone one time.
- Oh, this is cute.
- Oh yeah, I always care.
- And was like look this is kind of like.
- [Nat] Aww.
- You've gotta make a decision.
- Did you break up with her?
- No.
- She broke up with you?
- Yeah.
(all laugh)
- He was, he was massively
batting over his head.
- [Nat] It was never gonna happen,
he let you go.
- Do you have a girlfriend now?
- [Nate] I wasn't, right?
- I wouldn't say massively.
- [Gary] I think so.
- Does he have a girlfriend now.
- [Tyler] No.
- But I under rate Tyler a little bit.
He's way more charming then I think he is.
- You are, you're charming.
- I appreciate that.
I appreciate that.
- Tyler's charming, he's sneaky.
He's one of those guys
like a guy looks at him
and like no way, and they're like what?
How's he getting these girls.
Oh charm, charm.
You agree, John?
Yeah.
- [Cat] Oh, charms.
(Nat laughs)
- [Cat] Yeah, there we go.
- No, 'cause it works
the other way, right.
I don't know like everybody can.
Like I don't know, I don't
think I'm good at gauging,
I'm much better at gauging
if a guy's good looking
today than I did in my 20s.
In my 20s I was super confused.
I'd be like that's a
really good looking guy.
I'm like he's terrible with girls.
But personality really, fuckin' matters.
- Yeah, oh, my God.
- It does all matter.
- For sure it matters.
- Personality is so hot.
- It is so hot.
- There's also saying like--
- This goes back to what we said earlier
marry versus hooking up
is a very different game.
A guy that's a 10 but is like a dork
or like just super basic,
you may wanna hookup after
a bottle of Empathy Wines.
But actually dating, like
what are you gonna do?
- Or you have a bottle of wine
and they become better people.
- This is where guys
and girls are the same.
People don't think so, but
like I always tell them,
like young guys are so funny.
They're so confused by women and girls.
Like they don't realize girls are saying
the same shit they're
saying to their guys.
- Girls are so basic.
- [Gary] So are guys.
- Yeah.
- Oh yeah we are.
- But girls like go rogue.
Girls conversations are
more fuckin' gangster
than guys conversations.
- Oh, yeah.
How do you know that?
- 'Cause I'm kind of girlie.
- [Nat] Okay.
- [Tyler] That makes sense.
- [Nat] We dive into it.
- Yeah, I can like really.
- [Nat] We like that shit.
- Like I am like real girl,
like I can really have friends.
Like I'm very girl like.
I'm Amantha Bynes romantic
comedy movie watcher.
Like I, when had girlfriends,
I wanted to watch the
rom-com more than they did.
Like I'm, like I'm emotional.
I call my brand Empathy, guys.
Not like fuckin' kill it.
(Nat laughs)
Tyler get out of here.
- Tyler that's cute.
- Thank you.
- Good job on your love life.
- We can't wait, Tyler.
- Reach for the stars, babe.
- Keep charming them.
Keep going over your head.
Yeah, Nate.
- [Cat] Aw, poor Tyler.
- [Nat] That was amazing.
(Tyler talking off mic)
- [Cat] Okay, Tyler.
- So Tyler almost got fired.
- [Cat] I like that.
- [Nat] All right, but not Nate.
- How do we have a game?
- Oh, how do we have a game?
Well, we built a brand on mom truth.
We've done so many things.
We're on a live tour.
We go all across North America.
We fill theaters with women who come out.
We show them a good time.
We touch their hearts.
We touch their
- Loins.
Like with strippers.
- Yeah, we have strippers.
We have fun because do our work shit.
- Because we give women
permission to have fun.
- Period.
- Just permission.
You are--
- Period.
- You are a woman.
You are enough.
You are okay and the fact,
I think we've done 70 cities
and the women, the common theme is,
I had to move mountains to get out.
And so many women do
- For one night.
- most of what they do on their own.
And I can't speak to men,
- So much sense.
- 'cause our community is women,
but often they are pulling
the weight on the children,
the house, working full-time,
trying to manage relations,
friendships, and they have zero.
Like we've had women who
haven't been out in seven years.
Who make time to come to our show.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- So our whole mission--
- You're really doing a nice thing.
That makes me really happy.
Good job.
- We just, it's our job
to make them feel like
they have permission to be themselves.
That you are enough the way you are.
- Notice how I just put
a period at permission?
- [Nat And Cat] Yeah.
- Almost, if you analyze everything I do,
I'm just looking for permission.
I'm looking to create permission.
I'm looking to let kids not
listen to their parents.
I'm looking for parents to
not overcompensate their kids.
I'm looking for people to have
permission to be themselves.
- Yeah, and from a permission
to know that if you like,
you're gonna be okay.
But if you fail,
- You're like what?
- you're gonna be up.
- [Gary] Like what, I always say that.
What?
- Yeah, what?
- [Gary] What's gonna happen.
- Yeah, so our night
is our night, our book,
our game, everything across
the board is always like
you do it differently,
I do it differently,
but at the end of the
day we all love the same.
- And we all--
- Your kids love you the same.
My kids love me the same.
- We're good moms.
Everyone's like I'm a bad
mom because I do this,
that and the other.
We created a book and we created a game.
- Who gets to judge?
Real quick on this bad mom thing.
- [Nat] People judge themselves the most.
- Of course,
- Right.
- Like once and for
all, just on the record
while we're hanging who gets to judge
that you're a bad mom?
Who, your mother?
Because she did it a certain way?
Your sister, like your best friend?
Like judgment is fuckin' poison.
- I know.
It is poison.
- But when people ever
try to start talking to me
about being a parent.
Within seconds, I'm like, cool,
I cut them off and I go, I'm gonna let you
finish this thought and
then I'm gonna counter
with my opinion on how you're parenting.
Like what?
What are we doing here?
- [Nat] I don't know.
- I'm a bad mom?
Says who?
1947?
- We are trying to squash
that term permanent.
'Cause now it's become,
like I'm a bad mom.
But, no, you're not a bad mom.
You are the mom you are
and that will change today,
tomorrow, a year from now.
- It's words put together
manifesting from insecurity.
- Yeah, a 100% and that's
why people are like
how can you two go and
travel all the time,
leave your kids, do this, do that.
How do you not feel guilty.
And we're like 'cause we're
confident in what we're doing.
- [Gary] Period.
- We have a partner.
- Because you grew up
in a framework that caused you
to not give a fuck.
- 100% yeah, yeah.
- And we also don't
apologize for what we do.
- This is why I'm pushing
parents to let their kids fail.
- Oh, us, too.
So they can be resilient.
- You know and let your kids
take risks so they can feel
what it feels like.
- What it feels like.
- To be uncomfortable.
- A lot.
Otherwise we're raising
fuckin' zoo animals.
- But also, no if you--
- Seriously.
- If you think about it confidence
and self-esteem is gained.
It's earned, it's not given.
So you can not give it to your kid.
So what they have to do is--
- You know what's funny, though.
Or are you a blank slate
and what happens is parents
by showing their kids
that they don't believe
in them, eliminate it.
You know it's a very interesting,
you know it's one in the same.
What you're saying and what I'm saying.
When you, when that whole scandal
came out a couple of
weeks ago where parents
were buying their kids into college,
everybody rushed to,
like this is terrible.
What about the kid that
deserved to get into,
I went to the kid.
Ugh, that kid who knows that
their parents bought their way
into college.
- Yeah, they didn't
believe in me.
- Is telling their child
you're such a fuckin' loser
I so don't believe in
you that I had to buy.
Like it's that kid's finished.
The kid that was trying to get into Yale
and now's going to Michigan State
and knows they deserved it,
that kid has a fuckin'
chip on their shoulder
like the three of us.
And is gonna fuckin' kill the world.
- [Both] Yeah, yeah.
- Well, we also say.
Parenting also has to be uncomfortable.
Like you can't make it comfortable
because your kids have
to earn the feelings
because it's only gonna get
bigger as they get older.
So if they can't handle
the little feelings,
they're not gonna handle
the big feelings.
- The problem with parenting
to have other people judge
them not for their kids.
People make decisions.
- Their parenting
out of guilt.
- The parenting out of
the what the other parents
are gonna say, I can't wait, I can't wait.
- [Cat] For what?
- For what?
- For some parent to come up to me.
So, look my oldest is about to be 10.
- Us, too.
- Me, too.
- So what that means is, those kids
and I see it already
when I come to school,
those kids are starting
to get on Instagram.
Well, when they get on Instagram
they're gonna stumble
across the father of the kid
who's yelling on Instagram,
like fuck your parents.
Fuck school.
And so like, I'm only 36 months away
from getting somebody calling
me and saying, Mr. Vaynerchuk?
Yes.
This is Mr. Thompson.
My son is in your daughter's grade.
I'm like, Mr. Thompson how are you?
Listen I have a real problem.
I'm like fuck you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, fuck you.
You have a problem tell your kid
to stop consuming my content.
What the fuck are you talking about?
- People always ask us.
- I know you have a problem.
You fucking wasted your
time by calling me, dick.
That's really who has the problem.
- [Cat] Dick-bag, dick-bag.
- We always say like people come to us
like what are your kids gonna think later
when they watch this content
and they see the things you're saying?
- I'd think my mom was a fuckin' badass.
- And that's the dialogue.
- Instead of fooling shit.
You know what, every kid,
I get their ETMs.
You know what kids think of
parents that lead fake lives?
That their parents are full of shit
and they have no respect for them.
- Yeah, we actually have a
ton of teenagers who follow us
'cause they wanna see
- Of course, you do.
- What is happening.
What is this like and I'm--
- Facebook, YouTube, excuse me.
Facebook, YouTube put
your phone numbers in
'cause we're gonna try to
sneak in a couple of calls.
- [Cat] Oh.
- I'm having way too
much fun with the ladies.
(Nat growls)
But like we need to get some calls in--
- Oh, shit, it's going fast.
- It's going fast 'cause
it's the greatest show
you've ever been on.
- [Cat] Exactly, except for our own.
- Aye-oh.
- But anyways.
(Cat laughs)
- Plug it, plug it.
- Cat and Nat everywhere you can find us.
YouTube, Facebook Live.
- You know we're kind of in a
way the female version of you
'cause we are unexpected,
unexpected rogues.
- I love that.
- [Cat] You know what I mean?
- Yeah, I do.
- [Cat] You don't think that about us.
You see us and you're like.
- No, I thought that
about you when I saw you.
- Oh, okay.
- I just wanna say.
- I looked at your faces and
said these ladies are crazy.
- You wanted to say bitches.
You can say that.
- These ladies are crazy.
- No, I didn't say it.
- Okay, but you--
- But one more thing
you were saying.
- I know it's 2019.
I know you'd love it.
- This ain't over Cat-Nat.
If you say bitches.
- One more thing about
what's gonna happen when our kids friends
and their parents find
out about everything
that we're saying and doing
is we are now preparing
the dialogue, not only for our husbands
telling our children,
but us telling us our children
- Of course.
- That what we're doing is a good thing.
And you should be proud of us no matter
what anyone else says.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And so we're constantly
saying this to prepare--
- Guys.
- [Cat] But the dialogue
we have with adults.
- Your insular, thus you're
gonna make your world insular.
That's me too.
- [Nat] Be proud of us kids.
- You know what that's gonna do?
It's gonna be the greatest thing
that ever happened to your kids.
- Yes, oh, no.
- They're not gonna
be peer pressured.
But you guys this is, you are doing
the greatest thing for
your children, ever.
I believe in it so
much, you can't imagine.
- We do, too.
- Listen, I yeah
and I agree.
I think that if you are a
parent who is struggling,
I'm like stop looking at parenting advice
and go find who you are in order to.
Like we're so passionate about motherhood
and helping women feel
like they're not alone
and not isolated.
The amount of women
that have come up to us
and have said, you know, I
was close to killing myself
is actually off the charts.
- Every single show.
- Like every day?
- [Nat] Yeah, every day.
- Ever day?
- Yeah, every day.
- Guys, when your truth, when your pure,
when your 100, this is what you get.
- But we take that, we
honor that and we take it--
- No shit, the world thinks
we're rogue and crazy,
we're doing the right thing,
they're doing the wrong thing.
(Nat laughs)
No, no for real.
- I agree with you but, you
can live that truth every day.
With your kids, with your
everything that you do.
- Of course, it starts with you.
If you're insecure and you
hear what the alpha PTA moms
are gonna think of you.
You're fucked.
- [Cat] You're fucked.
That's in everything.
- That's right, Mr. Thompson I can't wait
for you to call me.
(Cat and Nat laugh)
As I can tell I'm fuckin' ready.
We already know you have a problem.
- [Nat] My husband is this--
- You have a big fuckin' problem.
- [Nat] My Husband--
- As a matter of fact, I'm
now gonna make a video.
The next day, when Mr. Thompson
calls me in three years,
the next day my video is gonna
be like hey, Ricky Thompson,
this video's for you.
A, your dad's a dick.
B, it's okay, I'll help you.
And we're gonna fuckin' coup
d'etat Thompsons household.
- [Cat] Yep, coup d'etat.
- What does that mean?
- [Gary] Look it up.
(Cat laughs)
- Look it up.
- Yes, sir.
- [Cat] Put it in my back pocket.
- What do you guys think of Empathy White.
(phone ringing)
- [Lindsey] Hello.
- Fuckin' amazing.
- Who's this?
- It's so good.
- [Gary] Lindsey, it's Gary Vee.
- [Lindsey] Hey, Gary Vee.
- [Gary] You're with the moms
that are so full of truth
it makes me uncomfortable.
- [Lindsey] Well, I met them in Morristown
and they are amazing.
- Morristown, New Jersey?
- [Nat] We did a show there.
- [Lindsey] Yeah, they did a show there
in winter.
- In fuckin' Jersey.
- [Lindsey] I went for my birthday.
- Oh, that one, that one,
- Oh, Lindsey.
- must have been, Jersey
girls are fucked up.
- [Lindsey] It was amazing.
- That was Lydia's fuck, right?
- Yeah.
- [Lindsey] It was so much fun.
I don't know if you guys remember me.
I had the nude, fur vest on.
- Of course, we wouldn't
forget your fur vest.
I wanted to rip it off your back.
- [Lindsey] You actually said that.
You said it was so
Jersey and you loved it.
- I did.
- [Lindsey] I'm a huge
fan of both of you guys.
My husband is a huge Gary Vee fan.
I'm a huge Cat and Nat fan.
- Well this is a great fuckin' family.
- [Nat] Shoot, there we go.
- And your family's clearly winning life.
(Nat laughs)
- [Lindsey] So my question is
I'm a new stay-at-home mom.
And I'm just kind of
like, I'm a hard worker,
but I'm kind of struggling
right now to find like my thing.
And I know, Gary, you're
always like content,
content. Content.
And I'm all about it but
what if you don't know
exactly what you wanna do.
- Well, it's better to make something
and try to figure it out,
than play in your head
and never do anything.
The reason I'm saying content.
Like most people don't know.
But the way to find out is to taste.
Right, like I always
think of it in food terms.
Like I always do this when I go out.
I love oysters and I'm
like you want some oysters?
Oh, I hate oysters.
Eight out of 10 people when
they say they hate oysters,
have never had one.
- [Lindsey] True, yeah exactly.
- That's what I think about life.
You don't, of course you
don't know what you like
or what you're passionate
about or what have you,
but the only way for
you to know is to try.
- [Lindsey] Is to try,
exactly.
- We just talked about,
you know everything that
we just talked about
the last five minutes
is about self-esteem.
If you're willing to make
a video of you cooking,
even though you don't know how
or you think you're great
at it or whatever it may be.
If you're willing to make a video
about your thoughts on
parenthood 10 years in.
If you're willing to
review wine like I did.
If you're willing to do a hot
take like Steven A. Smith.
If you have a point of view
of where Yanis is ranking
in the top five players
in the world right now,
that's a scary piece of content
if you've never put out
sports content in the world.
But if you actually,
secretly love the fuckin' MBA
and have a to take on De'Arron Fox's
upside over the next five years,
you could go on to become Erin Andrews.
You just don't know.
People don't know until they do.
So the reason I keep saying
content, content, content
is that's the answer
but it starts heavier.
It's starts a level up.
Which is you have to
give yourself permission.
To be willing to put out,
- Period.
(she laughs)
- That piece of content.
When you post a video of
your hot take on the Raptors
winning two games in a row,
are you ready for 11 or 12
of your best friends saying,
what the fuck are you doing?
- [Nat] Aha, that was us, yeah.
- Right.
- And also, if you aren't amazing at it,
it doesn't matter because
if it is you doing it
like wholly.
Like Nat and I don't know
what the fuck we're doing
90% of the time, but it
doesn't stop us from doing it.
We show up 100% and we go.
And sometimes it fails and sometimes,
sometimes it fails, sometimes we nail it.
But the people love
watching when we fail it
and when we nail it because it's us.
- And you know what, we just,
we don't--
- You guys are amazing.
- You just jump.
- You're just as amazing.
Just so you know.
- But just jump
and try something
and it's okay to change your mind.
If you put something out tomorrow
and then you decide that
didn't actually work
I wanna try something different,
don't be afraid.
We have changed so many times over.
- [Lindsey] I agree.
- And here's the key.
The key to all of this is
what's the alternative?
What, are you gonna live your whole life
saying what's my passion?
- [Lindsey And Nat] Yeah.
- I mean like what's the downside.
Like you're talking to three people here
who've completely had upside with knowing
that the only uniqueness we had
was the being 100% ourselves.
We live in a world now where
everybody can be a personality.
Right, so what happens?
That means there's a supply
that we've never seen before.
Where do you actually create uniqueness,
you create uniqueness in
being 100% your pure self.
Because if you're 80%, then
you look like everything else.
- Right and Lindsey if you
have the lady balls to wear
that fur vest to our show,
you have the balls to jump.
- The vagina's actually stronger.
- Yeah, yeah.
- If you have the vagina,
which you do, kill it, girl.
- Yeah, yeah, you got this.
- [Lindsey] Okay, I don't
wanna take too time.
- And the question,
real quick, real quick, Linds.
The question is you
probably felt comfortable
wearing that in the
environment of the safety
of the four walls created
by right, the truth, right?
- [Nat] Yeah.
- The question becomes are you then
willing to do that outside that box?
I think we're--
- Right and you know what,
honestly it was my first night postpartum.
- [Nat] Yay.
- [Lindsey] So I like went all out.
I did my hair.
I did my makeup.
I put on a cute outfit and I
had the best time of my life.
- [Nat] Aw, thank you, Lindsey.
- And one more thing, that
was Nat and I's second show
we'd ever done.
We had zero help.
(child sneezing)
- [Lindsey] God bless you.
- We had two team members
that did it with us
and we were ass-backwards
and we only have continued
to do it because we kept doing it.
Not because someone's like
you should keep doing it
and I have to tell you that
was just as scary for us
as it was for you.
- 100%.
- If you take the risk,
it only gets easier.
You just gotta--
- And come to another
show, it's better now.
(she laughs)
- It's better and--
- [Lindsey] I definitely
wanna go to another show.
Oh, and also I was the
one on your Live yesterday
who said the last one smells
like the Jersey turnpike.
(she laughs)
- Oh, so and Lindsey.
See whatever city you're close to DM us
and we'll leave you tickets, girl.
- Yeah.
- [Lindsey] Thank you so much.
- Thank you we appreciate it.
- [Lindsey] Oh, my god
I love you guys so much.
- And give your husband a big kiss
for being a Gary Vee
family, what the fuck?
- [Lindsey] He put me onto you, Gary.
He was like you gotta watch this guy,
he's amazing.
He listens to you all the time.
And I listen to Cat and Nat.
So this is like our perfect combination.
- It's the greatest show,
ever for your household.
- Ever, ever.
- All right one more.
I mean there's like nothing.
Listen when you have the
courage to be judged,
like the three of us are what
people don't understand is
for when the establishment judges me,
and they always do and
always will and always have,
what the establishment doesn't understand
is we get those messages.
I love it when the elite, ideological,
classic judge me, like Gary.
I get a lot of it now, especially now,
as I continue to get build
momentum and I laugh.
And I'm like you think
you're such a great person.
and you're a great person
in your insular world.
Living in your fucking ivory tower.
I'm in the fuckin' trenches with people.
I'm getting kids that are
17 who are taking photos
of a fuckin' rifle and posting
that this was in my mouth an hour ago.
I watched your video.
So, like I'm very glad that
you fuckin' went to Yale
and that you write op-eds for
the fuckin' New York Times,
but I live in real fuckin' world.
- Yeah, yeah and that's,
people who create content
for Instagram rather
for their community, and it
doesn't matter how many people
you have, it's the people
that you actually invest in
which is your, stop looking
at words, look to them.
- And by the way, by the way I never start
with a judgment of the op-ed Yale thing.
(phone ringing)
(answering machine recording)
I'm just doing my thing.
People wanna fuckin' judge this--
- [Cat] She's on message.
We leave her a message?
- Oh we leave a message quite seriously.
(Cat and Nat laugh)
- [Recording Voice] When
you finish recording
you may hang up or press
one for more options.
(machine beeps)
- Faith, you made the
biggest mistake of your life.
You put your phone number
in to talk to Cat and Nat
and I and here we are.
We called you.
- [Nat] You're not there.
- We wanted to be with you.
- Yeah, we did.
- It would have been something
you remembered forever
and guess what happened?
- You weren't there.
- And guess what?
If you do what everybody
does on this show,
you're gonna call back in a minute
and guess what?
We're not picking it up.
- We're not gonna pick it up.
- Shit.
- You missed it.
- Ramifications.
- Gonna be consequences.
- This is the four of us.
We all we lived with ramifications.
- But if I was her,
I'd call here 700 times
till I got through.
- Guess what?
- Sliding doors, babe.
- We are not answering, thank you.
Let's do one more.
- [Nat] Oh, my god.
- Oh, then, she's gonna be--
- What do you guys wanna say
in the last couple of minutes
that we didn't get to touch.
- Oh, my god.
I mean I feel like there's
a year we could go on,
but honestly just, I think that everybody,
everybody's gotta listen to you.
And honestly, we wrote
the book that we wrote,
"Mom Truths" and that's another thing
is that when they're like
oh, you're doing so well.
You sold all this many books.
You're a bestseller, yada, yada.
We're like oh, you guys seem
way more excite than we do.
We wrote a book just so we
could be called an author.
Just because it mattered to you.
What matters to us is our
audience and our people.
(phone ringing)
We wrote the book because
- Optics.
- We needed to have a book
that was real for moms.
The ones that should be delivered
when they leave the hospital.
No parenting books, but
this is the real deal.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- The truth.
- [Woman] Hello.
- Hello, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on with Cat and
Nat on the "Ask GaryVee Show".
- [Woman] Oh, my goodness.
Are you serious?
- Serious.
- Joking, it's a dream.
You're gonna wake up in a minute.
- [Woman] I never thought
this would happen.
- What's your name where are you from?
- [Woman] I'm from
Georgia, Atlanta, Georgia.
And I've never heard of you.
I just saw that they were
gonna be on your show.
I'm just being honest.
So that's why I was watching.
- Real quick, you never heard of me, Gary
or the ladies?
- [Woman] Yes, oh you, I'm sorry.
(both laugh)
I'm a huge an of Cat and Nat.
- I appreciate it.
Fair enough.
But you're quickly realizing
you now love me, right?
- [Woman] No, I mean I like you now
'cause I've been watching
the show this segment, but.
- Thank you.
- [Woman] Actually I wasn't
expecting to get a phone call
in a million years.
- So what can the ladies
answer for you?
- [Woman] I was asking when
is the Cat and Nat cruise?
- [Gary] Mhm.
- Okay so when is the cruise, wow?
You know we--
- What we say always happens.
- We are.
We're working on it.
- Did either one of you go on the
Thunder cruise?
- No.
- The stripper cruise.
- With John and Nate.
No, I did a wine cruise.
- [Cat] Oh, amazing.
- We should do a Cat and
Nat Empathy Wine cruise.
- [Nat] Whoo!
- Look like Nate's gonna
get his opportunity
to be a father.
- What the fuck is that.
- That's what happens on cruises.
- That sounds amazing.
(both laugh)
- It's gone full circle on this show.
- You know, everything--
- When does the cruise happen?
- We dream.
- We said that we were gonna--
- It's a layup.
- Girls, we said we were gonna on tour.
- You're gonna do it?
- we're gonna do it.
- Said we were gonna write a book,
we said we were gonna do
a girls weekend in Vegas,
that's coming up soon.
- Do you guys need a cruise partner?
I've got a great one.
- [Both] Yeah.
- Hook them up with Mirabelle.
That guy's awesome.
- So girl, if we said
there's gonna be a cruise,
there's gonna be a cruise.
We're working on the details right now.
We just got a contact.
- [Woman] 'Cause I
remember when y'all said
we're gonna do a fun show and
then fun show came and, yeah.
- [Cat] Yeah.
- [Woman] And I was like,
I was at the Atlanta show
back in September and it one of the best,
one of the best nights of my
entire adult life.
- You're life?
Well you know thank you so much.
And girl, we got you, we hear you.
We hear the people.
We listen to you.
It's going to happen.
- In the meantime, come
to Vegas in September.
- [Cat] Yeah, Vegas in September.
- [Woman] I might.
- Yeah, girl.
- Good.
- Yeah, Vegas can get crazy.
- [Nat] Yeah, well we can get crazy.
- No, Vegas is like dark.
- Oh, well the--
- [Woman] I don't know if
Vegas can handle y'all.
- Oh, Vegas can handle them.
- It'll be popping my cherry.
I've never been.
- You've never been to Vegas?
- Taking her in style.
- She's taking me and putting me on stage.
- Thank you so much.
- You've never been to Vegas?
- I know, it's a sad thing.
- We're doing things, okay.
We're doing--
- I'm only 22.
So there's still time.
- Forget it.
- we're doing life.
- Last one.
- [Cat] Wow, that was pretty funny.
- That was amazing.
- They're quite confident
these women on the phone.
I'd be kind of nervous.
- Oh, me too.
- No, you guys create an
ecosystem of no nerves.
- Yeah, they feel comfortable with us.
- Well, they're our people.
They know.
- How many selfies do you take a day?
- Not many.
We do a lot of Instastories.
- I understand, I'm talking
about when you're out
and about do people roll up on you?
- Oh, lots.
- Yeah, oh, with other people.
I thought you meant of ourselves.
- You know we have a naughty podcast,
a really naughty podcast.
- [Gary] That's great.
- It's like off the rails,
not what you'd expect.
- As it should be.
- [Nat] It's a business one
with a little bit of sex talk.
- Which is not into a lot, like.
- It's not sexy, sex talk.
- It's raunchy stuff.
- [Jose] Hello.
- Hello, who's this?
Jose what's up?
You're on the "Ask GaryVee Show",
with Cat and Nat.
- [Jose] No shit?
- [Nat] Shit.
- Yes, you put a fuckin' phone number and
and we called you.
- [Nat] It happened.
- [Jose] Oh, my god,
Gary, you changed my life.
You ladies are amazing.
I have one question.
My wife doesn't support me in
my entrepreneurialism goals.
- [Gary] Why?
- [Jose] She shoots me down.
We wanna move to Florida and
I don't think we should move
unless we have a nice amount of,
a nice sum of money to go.
And I've been flipping
houses and, as well Gary,
I cashed on four, amazing.
I started flipping things on myself.
But I have to tell you, Gary,
I bought eight cartridge for a dollar.
I bought two of them.
I sold them for $164 the next day.
- Let's fuckin' go.
- [Nat] Yo.
- [Jose] The next day, Gary.
$164.
- Dude, what do you
you think you're surprising me?
I know what the fuck this is.
I've been doing for 20 fuckin' years.
I'm just trying to put you on?
- [Jose] Yeah, Gary.
So I just went out this past weekend.
Went garage saling, anyway,
my wife don't support me.
She doesn't believe in
my goals and dreams.
We've been together 19 years.
We have five kids.
I don't know how to go about it.
I'm nervous.
- Over communicate
Like it's, brother, you over communicate.
- Okay as a woman, can
I give you my advice?
- Go.
- Let her know how you feel
rather than telling her how you feel.
Be like, this is important to me because
or I feel like I need to do this because.
Not, just like I'm doing this.
Communicate with her so she
feels she's part of the process
and then, just communicate--
- Let her know how it feels
when she shoots you down.
- [Jose] But this is the thing, ladies.
I don't mean to cut you off.
But years ago before we
bought, I bought a home.
I paid it off.
She used to help clean up houses.
Abandoned houses and we
used to get paid together.
You know what I mean?
- [Both] Yeah.
- [Jose] I just think
she just lost the drive
and the love for it.
Like she gets down and dirty.
She gets cleanings, she
does the high dusting.
She moves furniture with me.
Trash and everything.
And I guess over the years
she lost the love for it.
- Over the years, dude.
She's fuckin', she's the
mother of five children, bro.
- [Jose] I'm the father of
five children too, dude.
I was doing 90% of it.
I was doing things.
- what do you mean you--
- [Jose] I was the one
staying up all the nights
over night taking care of the
kids throughout the night.
Getting up with two hours of sleep
going to work.
- Let's go.
Listen I love you coming back at me.
- [Jose] Dude, my mom died at 16,
before she died she taught me how to cook,
taught me how to clean,
taught me how to do laundry,
taught me everything.
Not to depend on a woman.
- No, no.
- [Jose] To rely on myself
and that's the best thing
that she ever taught me.
Be the mother, single
mother she's out on--
- So, from one perspective
'cause there's always
two sides of a story.
But from one perspective
keep giving us context.
What do you think's happened.
You think she's become entitled?
You think she was, like what's--
- Tired?
What do you think's happened?
- [Jose] I spoiled her.
With everything, with the
cooking, the cleaning,
the taking care of the kids, the homework,
the hanging out with the kids.
Picking them up and to be honest you guys,
I hope you don't judge but she
likes to sit in the evening
and spend two or three hours
in watching reality shows
on her phone or YouTube
and it drives me crazy.
- Oh, man, bless his heart.
- [Jose] And then, Gary.
Check this out, Gary.
I'm on your level.
I don't want my kids going to college.
I'm trying to open the idea to them
on being an entrepreneur.
- Real quick, real quick,
real quick, back to my level, real quick.
- Go, go.
- Quick, back to my level.
I don't want my kids to go to college
if they don't wanna go to college.
- [Jose] I can't lose this,
keep talking.
- So like if my kids
wanna be the greatest professor
in a university of all time,
and that's in their soul.
I will support the shit out it.
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna force them.
- [Jose] I'm not forcing them, though.
- Real quick, I just wanna make sure
where I stand on this stuff.
I just want self-awareness
and leaning into children.
So out of five kids,
two of them are gonna wanna go to college.
Two of them are not gonna go to college
and one's gonna be in the middle.
You know what I mean?
So keep that in mind.
- [Jose] Oh, absolutely.
But before, now they're 18 and 19.
But I was doing this at 16, 17
and saying hey, guys,
try the Ebay or try this
or my second oldest, she
wants to be an architect.
Comes to find out she denied a job at,
no excuse me, she denied an internship
at an architect company because
she only spoke to my wife
and my wife said, no don't take it.
I look at it like that's
a great opportunity
for you to learn and I even
told her I wanna build a home.
I want you to build it for me
and that's not working for me.
She's like going her own route.
The same thing with my 19 year old.
I'm like, hey, you have business plans
of being an entrepreneur.
I'm not forcing him, Gary.
I'm going, hey you guys,
you want to get the time out
I'm here for you.
- Love that.
- [Jose] We can sit down
together, go over YouTube videos
whatever you wanna do.
You wanna know something, Gary?
And I know you guys gotta go.
My son's 16 years old.
He wants to be an actor and
he wants to be a producer.
So I said to him, hey,
let's go sit down together
and watch YouTube videos.
Arnie, I'm here to help you.
He didn't wanna do it.
I go up to him one day.
I say, hey, buddy.
Do you want me to stop asking you
what you want to do with your life?
Because I'm here to help you.
He goes, yeah, stop asking.
I'm like you sure?
Like what else can I do?
I'm not forcing it on them.
I'm bilingual, I'm Spanish.
I tell them, hey you
guys, take the time out.
Learn Spanish, I'm here to help you.
It's for free.
Gary, I spit so much of
your fuckin' knowledge
at my children, it's fuckin' crazy.
And they're not taking it.
I'm not gonna be the father.
I'm not gonna go,
you're gonna sit down and you're
gonna fucking learn Spanish
or the fuck, I'm not gonna do that
'cause it's gonna come
back to me down the line.
- Exactly.
- [Jose] I'm just trying
to open your eyes to it.
Like, hey, look at this video of Gary Vee,
look what he's doing.
Oh, yeah, but he's a millionaire.
I go listen, let go of the bullshit.
He still has the drive to
garage saling, you guys.
Don't you see that.
Like you could do it, too.
And I tell them, Gary.
Gary, I sit there.
I watch Rezzey Resells, Raiken Profits.
All these guys, BoxStorm, Ralli Roots.
And I sit down and I watch them.
Are they fun?
They're not fun, Gary, but I'm learning.
I'm fucking learning.
I'm trying to show them this,
but they're not getting it
and neither is my wife.
Like let's make these moves.
Like we'll have a house like.
- Real quick, real quick.
- We've gotta hustle.
- Real quick,
- Go, go.
- 'cause I love the fire.
Real quick deploying ambition
is a very fascinating game.
What you're trying to
do is deploy ambition.
And I respect that and I love you for it.
There's so much good, but when you give
you can't have expectation,
even when it's your own children.
What your doing is right,
but you can't enforce the next part.
Right?
- Right.
- Like you said, and you
said something very smart
at your heat moment,
which is I'm not gonna be
the dad that's gonna fuckin' sit them down
and say you have to do,
because it's gonna bite
me in the ass.
- That's right.
- So you're extremely
thoughtful about this.
I think if you take a
little bit of the ideology
out of, look they're 16.
Your circumstance was your
mom passed at that time.
You've learned all these things.
You, thank God, through
whatever success you've created
you've created a level of entitlement
and a level of cush for your kids.
And as much as that hurts
and listen bro, you're talking to me?
Mother fucker like the
delta between my life
and my sibling's life, let
alone my fucking kid's life,
is fucking crazy.
You're sitting right now
with two women who fuckin'.
She was in high school
fuckin' delivering papers.
Rolling fuckin' quarters.
- I saw the beginning of it.
- You know what her life's
gonna be like.
What her kid's life, excuse me, is.
When they fuckin' have a hockey player dad
and fuckin' mom that's making billions.
(Nat laughs)
(Jose laughs)
This is what everybody struggles with;
however, all three of us,
all four of us, excuse me,
have to take a big step back.
You've gotta separate
and it's very important.
You've gotta separate your
issues of noncommunication
and in two totally
different places that you
and your wife are from you and your kids.
- [Nat] So really.
- That's number one,
because a lot of that angst
is deploying on their kids.
Number two, it's amazing
that you're spitting it,
but you gotta spit it and
then take a step back.
Spit it and take a step back.
Don't forget your 16 year old can be 28
when it clicks for him and
then he has his whole life
to make it awesome.
So keep that a little bit in mind.
The bigger thing--
- I did.
- Well, great.
Well then that's it.
Put a period in that.
- [Jose] Like with the work you know,
my son told me one day.
Hey, you know dad I see
you working and running.
And, Gary, I'm also fasting
16 hours a day, too buddy.
So he tells me, hey, I wanna work out.
So I said, hey, I'm not
gonna go to you buddy
after school tomorrow you
come to me we'll sit down,
we'll go over beginning workouts.
I'll have a start and everything
and we'll take you from there.
Yeah, dad, cool.
Next day came.
I'm cleaning, I'm cooking,
I'm helping my other son
with his homework, he doesn't come down.
I'm not gonna say, hey Josh,
'cause I've been doing it for so long.
Hey Josh, come down.
Are you ready to start doing this?
He should have the drive himself.
I don't wanna keep on
me being, hey, you know,
reminding him and reminding him.
I mean you would think
that within yourself
you would find that drive and--
- One thing, the reason this is happening
is because you've been doing this over
and over and over, again.
You can't have the drive for him.
He's got to have
the drive for himself.
- 100%.
- And number two, parenting is repetition.
That's what it is.
You plant a seed and sometimes
it doesn't grow for years
but it's the point that,
it might like Gary said,
it might not click til
28, but it's not about,
at 16 he's in his head, that's their job.
And then what you do is, you show, you go
and you let them fuckin' fail.
Let them not workout and he fails
and you catch him when
he falls, a little bit.
You let him fall, though
and you're then like,
get back up again.
That's what parenting is.
- And the key, I'm sorry
- No.
- For jumping in.
The falling down's key.
I see a lot of modern parents thinking
falling down is skinned knee
and I think falling down is
your arm being ripped off.
And in the delta is a
very interesting debate.
Like it's an important debate.
- Let them, let them fall.
- Let me ask you a question.
- [Jose] Go, go, go.
- Do you give these children money?
- [Jose] No.
- Don't fuckin' bullshit me.
Do the parents give them any money?
- [Jose] Hold on, hold on, hold on.
My two oldest, the 18 and 19
girls, they work at Target.
My 16 year old son, he
works for my wife's boss.
Like he goes to his
house and does the lawn.
My 12 year old daughter,
she has a babysitting gig.
My wife's girlfriend
also, for her daughter.
My 12 year old watches her
and then my nine year old son,
I mean he's nine, hey, pick up
the trash here's two dollars.
- He's nine.
That's not the question I asked you.
I didn't ask you if they have a job.
I asked you is do you give them money.
- [Jose] No.
- What entitlement do
they have in your opinion.
- [Jose] I don't know.
I mean give me like an example.
What do you mean by that?
What entitlements?
- How do you think
they're spoiled?
Why do you think they're soft?
- Oh, because of me.
- Because you're spitting
this for 10 minutes, 11
minutes that everyone's soft.
Which is amazing.
I think everyone's soft, too.
But I'm curious what your perspective is
on why they're soft.
- Since they were babies,
since they were babies
I was doing the laundry.
Don't do your laundry, I'll do it for you.
I'll cook for you.
I'll clean for you.
I'll do this for you.
And over the years, like
the other day, dude.
Like it is what it is,
I go upstairs the bathroom's really dirty.
Like you guys, I've been cleaning it
for you guys for how long?
It's just like in one ear, out the other.
- Here's the problem.
- [Jose] I just might
as well do it myself.
- I'm gonna tell you
quickly a spoiled child
is actually not monetary.
A spoiled child is someone who
gets given or gets fixed for.
So, let's say they're having a problem,
the parent steps in and fixes it for them.
The bathroom is dirty.
Spoiled has nothing to do with monetary
and a lot of people like,
they're spoiled they get.
You can actually have, but
also have an unspoiled child
by letting them experience life.
So if their bathroom's dirty,
natural fuckin' consequence.
It's dirty, they have to
piss in it and that's it.
That's the way it goes.
It's letting them understand
that their life has consequences.
But you've been doing it for them forever.
- Jose, what the fuck are you
cleaning the bathroom for?
(Nat laughs)
They're playing you like a fuckin' drum.
- The reason they're
not doing it,
- I know, dude but listen.
- is cause you clean the bathroom.
- That's wow, bro, that's on you.
- Yep, don't, yeah.
- I'm just tired of asking.
I'm tired of tired of just--
- Stop, doing it.
- Dude, dude.
No, no, dude.
This is on you bro.
You told us story just now.
That I--
- And you know what else man?
- Jose hold on.
- Go, go, go.
- You told a story that you cleaned it,
you cleaned it, you cleaned it.
And then you're yelling
at them to clean it.
They don't know how.
And then you say, fuck
it, I'll just clean it.
That last part is why you're losing.
- Dude, I'm 41.
- I don't give a fuck
if you're 100.
- [Jose] I'm tired of asking.
(all laugh)
- [Cat] Then stop asking.
Stop doing it.
Stop asking.
- I don't give a fuck if you're 100.
Never clean the fuckin'
- Who is--
- Bro, Jose, listen to me.
I love you, I love you.
Never clean the fuckin'
bathroom again, dog.
Never, again.
- You know what's crazy?
Listen to me.
My wife is, she tells me
and I have a bad habit of it
she goes, honey stop letting
the kids ruin our night.
And they almost did it again last night.
- She's right.
- [Jose] Because I went upstairs.
We both went up and she
flipped out a little bit,
but I was flipping out,
and she said, no, no, no,
let's go downstairs.
I wanna watch a movie don't
leave this room again tonight.
You been, and I almost did.
I almost went back upstairs to clean.
You know what, she's right.
- She's right.
You're wrong.
- let me sit down
and we saw the movie "The Upside"--
- Jose i don't give a fuck
what movie you saw, bro.
(both laugh)
Stop cleaning the fuckin' bathroom, man.
Stop with the fuckin' bathroom.
- [Jose] Dude, I just read rights.
- Where do you live?
- In Westchester, New York.
- Email me your address.
I'm gonna fuckin' spy on you ass.
If you ever fuckin' clean the bathroom,
I'm gonna hire some big ass dude
to beat the fuck out of you.
- Go on Google Maps and
watch me from there, dude.
So listen, all is well.
- Jose, listen to me.
- Don't you think.
- Listen to me,
Jose listen to me.
- Go, go, go.
Go, go.
- Listen to me you're
doing such a cliche thing.
You're trying to control everything
and then you're complaining about it.
Either, clean the bathroom
and shut the fuck up
or never clean the bathroom again.
- [Jose] And it'll be like pig styes?
- No, I don't give a fuck.
(Jose laughs)
Listen to me one more time.
- [Jose] How am I fuckin'--
- Jose, listen to me.
You like me, you think
I'm giving you value.
Listen to me, either--
- I love you, Gary.
- Good, so ready?
- I love you.
- Go.
- So either A,
I'm gonna give you two options.
Either A, clean the bathrooms
and shut the fuck up
or B, never clean the
fucking bathroom again.
- [Jose] Let them be pigs upstairs.
- 100%.
- [Jose] All right,
fuck it my wife's right.
You guys are right.
I'm not gonna--
- Let's go, see ya.
That was fucking amazing.
Ladies, thank you so much.
- [Nat] Thank you.
- That was fuckin' amazing.
The question of the day.
You guys get to ask it.
Thousands of people, 100s
of thousands of people
over the next year will watch this video
at some point and listen to it,
what is your question of the day?
- Okay so this is our beef right now.
Is authentic something you are
or is it something
everyone's trying to be?
- Interesting.
Well, we're about to see the answers.
Cat and Nat, moms of fuckin' truth.
Tell me, I wanna make
sure I have funny feeling
after this I'm like, wow.
there's a, you're about to
grow your dude fan base.
- Ooh.
- 'Cause you guys are me
and I'm you.
So please tell everybody books,
games, what are you guys,
I wanna make sure.
Let's throw some right hooks.
- Cat and Nat everywhere.
- CatandNat.com?
- Catandnat.ca.
- CA, someone owns
fuckin' .com.
- Well step the fuck up and buy it.
- [Cat] Okay, fair.
- At catandnat.ca.
- Step up and buy it.
You guys are building a real brand.
- Yeah, no we are and then--
- Let the squatter make a couple of bucks.
- Is .ca really that bad?
- Yes, .ca Canada doesn't mean anything.
- All right, got it.
It's our website, but fuck it.
- Got it doesn't mean it's a single thing.
- And them Mom Truths is everywhere.
We have games.
- And you gotta come to our live shows.
You can get all the
tickets at catandnat.ca.
- Are dudes allowed?
- Oh.
- In outfits.
- 'Cause they're strippers.
- Well men strippers, but dudes.
- Oh, it's man strippers.
- Fuck yes, women.
But you know what, we
have the better like,
they come with their wives
and that's the first
date like they've like--
- What are we doing here?
Is Empathy Wines like the
official wine of these ladies now?
- We're trying.
Hello, yeah.
- What does it mean?
You're trying to steal
fuckin' money from my guys?
- No, no, we're not.
We haven't even talked.
We just got drunk with Nate.
(people talking)
- No, and you know what?
If they don't sell it in
the theater we can give it.
- Yeah, we could.
Anyways we've got lots of ideas.
- Steals money from my guys.
- Just come to Cat and Nat,
in the Bay area.
We got this.
It's with a C not a K like a kitty cat.
- Meow.
- Thank you.
- [Nat] Thank you.
- Keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
On this Episode, all hell breaks loose.
- [Nat] That is our thing.
Oh, God for another day.
- [Cat] Always hell breaks loose,
I don't know why.
- Oh, no.
- [Cat] That's like our tag line,
hell breaks loose.
- [Gary] The way, you think
about the narrative of that?
That Jose caller, that call
to end with Jose saying,
"Fuck it my wife was right".
Yesterday, I did not see
Joe Namath's question day
being about abortion.